notre président a accepté volontairement
de coopérer avec la justice et que il a
démontré au juge que les deux plaintes
ils n'ont aucun aucun fondement il ya
seulement de mobile politique derrière
tout ça qui a qui avait comme objectif
de d'entacher l'image de la lutte du
peuple du sahara occidental à travers
l'image de co2 solidaire
ça c'est une chose et l'autre chose ce
que le juge a a décidé de ne pas donner
suite aux demandes et la partie de
l'oxydation l'accusé de l'accusation en
terme des mesures préventives puisqu'il
n'a vu aucun lien ce lieu entre le le
planter le et le président sahraoui
quand il le lit le veni avec il veut ni
à cause de son hospitalisation et l'état
de santé il fois les causes de sa
présence et le sol espagnol ne sont plus
là ou bien s'il reviendra chez lui et de
reprendre à ses fonctions
présidentielles
pas de doute là dessus